I just did what I had to do for work and
it was a job for me whether we're
shooting him some of them was stabbing
him some of them was batting them at
this point I look back and I wish I
never did it
young Johnny like X Gambino enforcer
hitman I'm an advocator now for children
prison reform second chance program and
also a co-author of several books and
this is my story I grew up in normal
household I guess Albanian typical
household I was raised as a ballplayer
and a fighter since I'm a little kid my
dad believed in the boxing world
fighting his concern was war with
education in streets and being able to
survive coming from a communist regime
in Albania and coming from the Lower
East Side where he they taught us to be
tough guys I guess interview off his
five major families Gambino family is
one of the stronger families out of the
five so I started getting involved with
the Gambino family one of them was my
baseball coach as a young kid was
Anthony and Albert Ruggiano their father
was nicknamed fat Andy Russia Anna was a
made member of the Gambino family and
Murder Inc he was a guy that raised me
and also through Lucky Luciano was a
famous gangstas first cousin Charlie
looks young which we called Blackie he
was a partner with my uncle and a
gambling den out of South Bronx
I was raised by these guys as early as
five years old I was in gambling dens
and I was at different card games crap
games and I was exposed to other
gangsters through them and later on in
life as a teenager I started running
tickets and numbers and bookmaking slips
from a local delicatessen that I worked
at and the back room was used as
payphones for illegal gambling and the
horse betting so I would run slips
across the street to Lucchese guys Lewis
and George Gaddy I dated the daughter of
I guess as years went on I started
becoming an enforcer without knowing I
was becoming one I started going to the
gym regularly as a fight or a boxer with
a lot of guys from the street in the
middle of collecting debts for gambling
at sports and classrooms they would ask
me eventually if I could add trouble
collecting to hurt them and it became a
regular business for me as far as hurtin
guys I got used to it I got forceful
when my bosses wherever they may be at
that time would tell me what to do at
that time it was a lot of guys from a
little KC family
actually running around doing those
things for later on it became the
Gambino family as I got old as the years
went on I'm working in selling drugs in
Rikers Island which is one of the bigger
County prisons that everybody from our
neighborhoods in the Brooklyn and Queens
end up going to if you get locked up was
25,000 inmates and I started working for
Angelo Ruggiero known as a real tough
guy he asked me to start moving heroin
within the prison system which I started
doing from that I started doing some
shootings baseball bat beatings I've
been accused of shooting close to 60
people I believe they accused me shoot I
think that number is exaggerated and
it's ought to say how many of those
people I killed but I would say well
over a dozen of those people have died
by accident I baseball batted one of my
friends till I got accustomed to being
violent unfortunately for some friends
some of it was business and some of it
just became a natural thing to lead to
to hurt you kill unfortunately that was
part of my life for being against as I
drew in the mob world like any job you
want to be the best at what you're doing
you know the mentality of us even know
what's the bad light for the crazy life
is to be respected and to make a lot of
money so as a kid I was actually slow
walking more than my friends my friends
were a lot more dangerous than me
coming from Brooklyn Queens to make
Avenue and a lot of my friends were
already shooting killing stabbing and as
the years went on I started to bypass
them I started to get more vicious but
also more intelligent I was raised by
guys like fighting a guru Gianna
who taught me to be quiet but also
taught me to be vicious you know what
you don't realize while you're in the
street there's all kinds of tolls that
you're gonna pay emotional and physical
at about 19 I get stabbed up for the
first time I get stabbed up two
different occasions I got about a 120
stitches in my chest at one time I
believe I got about 80 something in my
head I was stabbed in the head you start
accepting the violence and you start
accepting that you're playing roulette
with your life but not much regard of
that you think you're almost invincible
so I think some of the tools is that and
then as you're doing the killing and the
beatings and the herding of
individuals I think you just take it in
stride but some we're doing though down
the line you're gonna pay the price
mentally with it it's gonna take effect
this murders and the shootings I did and
prosecutors door in these cases talked
about how I just nonchalantly went to go
eat afterwards or I went to the beach I
didn't really understand what did they
mean by it
that's how detached you become not
realizing they're trying to show how
callous you become in the life and I
think that's my biggest reason why I'm
so candid about it because I'm trying to
teach kids there's so much suffering
that goes on not just on the victims my
victims other victims the families my
family and my personal fight with myself
to control my rage there's a mental toll
on you that I work on every day almost
like an alcoholic are you getting more
intelligent in the life and you start
growing up and maturing as you get older
and you're going through some of the
violence she did you starting to
recognize there really isn't that
loyalty that you believe there is as a
naive kid you start watching the
treachery the double-dealing people that
are killing their best friends killing
family members with no regard and you
start understanding that this is not
about loyalty this is about money all
and what I believed in as a kid started
changing and the ties that I grew up
with that I really respected they're
gone and move far away from this life
either lost their lives were murdered or
imprisoned for life and I started to
step back and really take a look at what
I'm involved in and I started seeing a
treachery when I went on the run when I
got caught I was in Brazil and while I
was on the run and in Brazil
Penitentiary's I watched two major crime
families the Bonanno family about 14
made guys captain and bosses the whole
hierarchy started cooperating and also
my own family to Gambino family started
cooperating and these guys aren't the
only ones cooperating these guys in all
around the country bosses from every
family every state that have been
cooperating and it kinda opened up my
eyes how did I meet my kids like this
why would I set these Penitentiary's in
Brazil for years at a time fighting for
my life in those concentration camps
when I spent two-and-a-half years
Penitentiary's and just keep getting
news after news of these captains and
all these family horses of all these
families cooperated and I finally when I
came back to the United States that I
decided to throw a towel and and change
my life ever since then I never turned
back I try to be as honest as possible
to help the kids not follow the path and
I actually grew up and believed in and
thought I would die following I left
four children behind like a jackass
believing in the loyalty of that life
and I have the Johnny and Jean show it's
a podcast and what I'm trying to do is
reach kids that had been in trouble or
parents that don't know what to do what
kids are in trouble I'm trying to reach
those kids before they get in trouble
and for those kids that been first-time
offenders for that second chance program
it's not a life that's conducive to
having a good life and I tried to convey
to city kids by saying to them listen I
promise you I'm the real guy and I
survived it and I think there's a reason
and a purpose why survives it so I could
save some kids lives and the nonsense
belief that this life is built on
loyalty it's the furthest thing from the
truth it's about money only and it's
self-preservation and that's really the
truth about the American Mafia
[Music]